[Music]
morning I can't quite see yet its 541
after leave in 10 minutes to make it to
yoga on time does anybody else for
context does anybody got LASIK surgery
leave me some comments below
[Music]
we survived yoga class and I'm not sure
how I'm feeling about this in screen
fingerprint reader I don't know if it's
my finger like every time it takes like
three tries just kind of frustrating cuz
if I'm trying to open up my screen
really quickly like it's not maybe it's
a me problem I'm not sure if this is a
universal thing if anybody else is
having issues so then it curating my
home screen but right now this is what
I've got on it Instagram Twitter Gmail
Spotify Maps Facebook my phone which I
don't actually ever talk on the phone
and this somehow moved up so you got the
YouTube studio YouTube snapchat and
Chrome's so I'm going to make my youtube
video live right now here it is this is
a massive Oreo unboxing your videos like
it's been raining so bad outside and
meat sticks out for a walk but I just
don't think it's time yet
oh boy we're testing out this water
resistance now in the rain look at this
wide angle pop wide angle one
2x since I left you guys last I preset
my fingerprint sensor because it's not
scanning I don't know maybe it's my
fingerprint I'm not sure but this dog is
soaked and he is so disgusting
he smelled white rot where'd you go yeah
get that cone mark it up oh but see
we're going this way so I'm gonna make
some breakfast now and I'm gonna use my
Samsung to film myself making breakfast
front-facing video I can't find a bowl
yes as a bowl to mix up some a March 6
today is actually more sick so we are in
luck see how this looks now it's good at
the zoom there it is - looks really good
[Music]
play the new Billy Irish song I know
this is a Sam's like a video that's here
but it's a good kind of song
how many can we take into picture ultra
wide picture here's a zoomed in egg
picture and here's a 2x2 live focus use
the left two lanes to turn left onto
fourth Street okay okay cool this is
really riveting content guys this is the
first time that I'm using Google Maps on
the s10 plus we are off to get my
haircut I don't know how much more
entertaining it can make this vlog
because the weather's trash I had really
big plans for today but instead this is
what you're getting getting this
beautiful option this is what I decided
to leave the house in and I have to live
with it because you're watching the
video I don't want your judgment let's
get a zoom in let's get a 2x zoom in
there we are
wow I'm just hoping that this video
footage looks as good as it does on this
screen on other screens because that's
one of the dilemmas that I have with
Samsung is everything looks great on the
phone but that
to my computer it doesn't look as good
this wide-angle is so great good we're
doing a camera review today three guys
think of the new hair basically the same
hair just clean and cut and a little bit
brighter I'm basically just using this
little segment here you see what it
looks like when I'm filming the back
camera in the wide-angle I haven't
vlogged it so long it's like I forgot
how to do it so what's that look like if
that's there got you guys here on my
dashboard look at that I'm in frame this
is good this is actually not bad little
adjust here let's go get some dinner
this jacket is really loud hope you guys
are really enjoying this video it's
definitely my best work this is my best
work we're in trouble
my hair is so clean I don't even know
how to act play Mike Shinoda
[Music]
so at dinner and my gosh guys the
fingerprint sensor is driving a nuts
like it works maybe once every five
Chinese but you have to be so particular
it just a super precise about it I don't
want to keep like parking on like
negative things because you guys are
just going to say just seeing here and I
hope fangirl obviously you're gonna be
complaining no it's exactly not working
I'm not being crazy this is this it's
not working the good thing is I'm
obsessed with the camera I'm gonna film
a little bit more here I may have to
turn this into a 2 day testing video my
days have over it's not supposed to rain
tomorrow so fingers crossed that I can
take this outside and sunny shots for my
takings a bit
and I'm so soon din to this butter
chicken I can see the ingredients like I
can actually I could tell you everything
that's in it here's our 1 X and of
course be wide angle I'm so under the
wide angle I really really like it good
morning welcome to day 2 with the
Samsung s10
I would be lying if I said this was
actually day 2 but this is actually date
there yesterday I was busy and they get
a chance to film anything but right now
I'm gonna go and I take some photos with
this thing but first and reset the
fingerprint because I'm still having
trouble everyone kept giving me
suggestions you're pushing too hard
you're not pushing hard enough you need
to move your finger down you need to
move it up you need to move it to the
side you need to move it to the left ok
I get it
[Music]
like it really never works on the first
try
another really cool feature on here is
their power shares so I actually forgot
to charge theoretically I forgot to
charge them they're charged but for the
sake of this demonstration this is super
cool so you basically slide down here
and this will give you a wireless power
share option so when you turn that on
this gives you the instructions it says
put the center of your phone back to
back with another device it's now
charging this is pretty cool because I
feel like it's an emergency situation
where you want to charge your headphones
or you want to charge something else
that is in need of charging like your
friend's phone who may have forgot to
charge it and you don't have another
charger I really like this feature I
think it's super fun and that's gonna be
something that's probably standard in
most phones from now on especially if
they have an accessory like in the
iPhone to charge my ear pods that would
be fantastic
maybe in the next iPhone but for now
it's actually going to say the hike is
beginning Wow
it's chilly might not look cold it's
sunny but I've got two jackets this is
the Will Rogers State Park this is a
really nice hike at the mouth 2.1 mile
loop I forgot to download all trails on
my Android phone that I use this I love
with that because it'll show you where
you hike
everything
this is the wide angle of your facing
camera so this is the back of the camera
I'm super into the wide-angle lens like
it's actually really really cool it is
something that I do wish was on me on
your phone I feel like I'll probably
implement that this year because it's
about time let's look pretty cool I
wasn't as steady as I probably could
have been so I can see how this can be
able to get some shots that's right
now we just did a quick little hike to
get some videos and some photos so far I
am enjoying the phone a lot the screen
is just it's so beautiful something that
I can't really show you in the video
because you have to just see it with
your own eyes
it's kind of hard taking pictures in
these lighting conditions because the
lighting is so harsh so hopefully some
of them turned out okay getting some
good light focus is interesting because
the different live focus backgrounds I
mean some of them if you're standing too
far away it kind of blurs your body so
if you aren't close enough you're gonna
kind of get that effect
yeah we are back from my day with the
s10 is actually like two days it's
actually three days technically I'm not
even sure at this point but I really
been enjoying this phone and I don't
want you guys to think that because the
fingerprint sensor isn't working for me
very well but that's deterring me from
liking this phone overall I will be
doing a follow-up video once I've spent
a little bit more time with it I'd say
probably my favorite features right now
obviously I do so much with photos and
videos is the video looks really good
my only complaint though is the
ultra-wide doesn't have image
stabilization so you can really tell
when you're in that mode it is a little
bit shaky but mad the wide-angle looks
so great it is kind of shocking to see
like some of the stuff like this is from
a phone like this looks so good look how
good this looks I mean I'm a little
biased cuz this is my own video but it's
just super smooth like some of the
photos I will say that some of these
background effects they're a little
aggressive I did read a couple comments
where people saw that the white ceramic
looks kind of cheap you might think that
looking at this video because it does
kind of have just like a really basic
white look like it kind of looks like
plastic in the videos but when you see
this thing up close and actually have it
in your hand like it feels a completely
different experience like it has a sheen
to it it has like this nice finish like
it does not look cheap at all I've also
been experimenting with different
fingerprint patterns I'm super happy
with this phone I know am i Justine
probably expecting me to say terrible
things about it but I really don't have
anything bad to say other than the
fingerprint sensor which is still sort
of a new tech anyway this video is
probably five hours long at this point
and going to end it now thank you guys
for watching thank you for all of your
comments let me know what you would like
to see in my follow follow-up video in
the meantime I'm gonna go finish editing
this video and admire
all my wonderful photos and videos that
I got I'll see you later
[Music]